[Music]
foreign
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I bring on
interesting guests and today's
interesting guest is Justin Waller
welcome to the show glad to be here
um tell the people a little bit about
you absolutely Justin Waller have
YouTube Jay Waller also have quite a bit
of real estate in America and
construction so
um as everyone knows I help guys online
in every area of Life you've seen my
channel you probably know and then we do
our best to help guys develop themselves
and get a position where they can come
in the war room or join the real world
Etc
a bit
different in the online space
because you had a whole like you ran a
whole construction company before you
even got on YouTube right yeah I had had
a whole life and still do have a whole
life so you still do that oh yeah I have
200 employees Oh I thought I thought you
sold it or something no no no no we uh
we just had our best first quarter ever
and last year we broke all our Revenue
goals uh it's the company is in a place
now where I have adult I'm the youngest
person in my office
so I've legitimately professional adults
that run the place they get bonus quite
well to run the company and so the
business is 13 years old and so for that
reason you know there's a lot of systems
in place there is a lot of deep-rooted
relationships with vendors and customers
and clients and and a lot of the guys in
the field have been with me for a long
time so yeah it runs it runs like a top
now I do get daily reports every day and
there's something I don't like I'll
drill into that and I'll make phone
calls but generally it's just to one
person in whatever business whether it's
in the real estate business or the
construction business or even this
online business
I call one person uh I think there was a
study that said
a manager can only manage about five to
six people Max and so now I have
somebody in the construction company
that manages everyone and I talk to that
person and if I really have a life or
death conversation which has not
happened this year
and we're in what April or May I can't
remember April
um
and so that's how that happens I just
get a report from each business each day
and if I see something I'll pick up the
phone and call but generally it runs
quite well and then we do quarterlies I
wanna I wanna do that yeah yeah when you
just call one person yeah no I get it I
get it but but you know I know what you
mean though like about building the
systems because we just um did that with
like recruiting so all right it's like
so nice when they start to be able to do
it on their own and you don't have to
interfere right so every like so every
person in your organizational board I
don't know if you have one
but every person in our organizational
board has five roles and
responsibilities and there's a
statistical metric attached to it so I
get those metrics every day for the
office positions and it trickles down
from the field and I know
every job we're on who what Foreman is
running that job if it's on track off
track the whole thing from my office
staff to my managers I know how much
money we made today I know every son of
a that spent a penny like that's
all there I know what AR is it's just
this big report I just tell Siri to read
it and just I keep driving and just
listen to it then
pick up the phone or text yeah I'm not I
gotta learn how to do that yeah I'll
show it to you when we get there yeah so
um you're also it's also really
interesting because you said you came
from Louisiana yeah I was born in
Louisiana and raised so and now you're
successful you have a social media
following you're in great shape
um you live this crazy life how does how
does one get there like where did where
did this start
it was funny you say that I made a post
last night in the War Room actually
um
I'd made a post that I paid my dad's
house off and somebody said to me I'm
really upset with myself I I had this
goal to do that and I had done it yet
and he was talking about like how far he
should be and
the reason I bring it up is because what
I said to him is a lot of times you have
internal growth
so for me
I was taking care of my fitness long
before I was on the internet I was
taking care of my business I was trying
to have the best style I I was conscious
of you know in Louisiana
and I was reading books and I was doing
all these things so it was all this
internal growth
so
when the time came where I went to go
online I feel like it was substantially
easier for people to accept me in the
online space being that as I had done
all these things like in the real world
particularly around business because
a lot of people that I do interviews
with and spend time with they make their
money from the internet and I think when
you when you look at particularly the
guys they're like you do what for a
living that's how you got here okay I
respect that I'll collab with you and so
in a lot of ways I think I grew like so
if Myron and Walt respected me in some
way they let me come on the show or had
me on the show Rolo Tate Sterling all
those people I just think there's a
certain level of respect I got from the
internal growth I had done over a decade
and they're like oh no that makes sense
you can come on you'll do well you know
and I have them to think for in a lot of
ways and you coming on your show I mean
this is a big channel it's a
million that's a million yeah but it
wasn't when you came on
but the point I'm making is is for me
how do I go from Louisiana
to London right with you right
I think
that any young man if he wants to exit a
small town if he works on his stuff in
his small town and develops himself if
he were to go out and then try to take
that internal growth and outwardly grow
that that's a possibility whether you
live in Louisiana or Ohio or Indiana or
what have you
so and in fact I think it's probably a
pretty good strategy because if you live
in a small town
and you just up and moved to Miami
it's going to be I think it's a
much better decision to truly grow
internally and truly get confident where
it's a little bit boring
because you're gonna need a lot of money
to come to London a lot of money to go
to Dubai a lot of money to go to Miami
I just think it's a better place to be
and the funny thing is
before I went online I don't think I was
as proud
but what I've come to learn is the
further I get away from home the prop
the more proud I am of where I come from
you know and I don't ever want to like
leave that behind because I think it's
the part that people find to be genuine
about a person like where they're from
you know and the fact that they stay
close to that you know when I leave here
and I go to my room tonight we put
country music on or doing whatever I
have to do or unfolding my who's
your favorite country artist George
Strait or Aldine I would have to say
good choice yeah I mean you can't not
like Morgan Wallen all right I'm such a
Morgan Wallen fan yeah no you hear
his new song no have you heard uh
sand in my boots
no I haven't heard that one
no way
it's good it's good I like the one he
just released it's um
I don't want to stick it but I like I
hit to my head I can't
um my hometown I like that one nice yeah
I think good country music's good for
your soul
it's like the only music that hasn't
been corrupted in my opinion completely
I it got a little poppy but I think it I
think it's like a good religion it
stayed to its roots in a way yeah like
it's not letting anybody break any crazy
loss you've thought about coming out
with a red pill what country
side note you sing
uh you know what that's Tristan
wow look at we could I could play the
guitar you could say maybe yeah it could
be a red pill album yeah it could at
least be a tick tock yeah yeah so
Louisiana
um did you have siblings were you close
with your parents or was that like
no so it was broken home for sure uh mom
cheated on my dad multiple times with
guys from church
from church yeah from church yeah
30. what kind of church was it the
normal non-denominational really it was
crazy when I was a kid we go to church
and people were like speaking in tongues
and falling on the floor and
yeah they would speak in tongues you
ever seen that
um on YouTube never in person oh I've
seen it in person it's crazy North
Louisiana man is it real
I think it's yeah yeah dude I
think it's when people put
their hands in their hair and like close
their eyes like act like they're getting
lifted and stuff I I am I try not to be
sacrilegious ever I've just seen some
things man it's just like oh you're
doing this but you're you're saying this
but you're doing that yeah you know and
what is a red pill it's like calling
everything out for its it's
really just a Pursuit Of Truth right so
I've seen some things I don't it just
kind of turns me off in time but uh yeah
two guys from church so you're from a
broken home your mom cheated on your dad
oh yeah and then the dusty courts
everyone put us in a foster home for
sure they were going to if we were gone
again there was a bit of violence going
on so
um
it just my mom yeah tough tough
situation for sure and so
um then you graduated high school and
what where'd you go next yeah so
it was kind of one of those things
whereas I didn't know how to get out of
my town and unless I play sports
and so I played football baseball into
my junior year
and then I found out that baseball
scholarships were partial and I didn't
want to play D7 basketball you know so I
ended up quitting those to gain some
weight and play football so I went and
played football and then when I got done
I had a construction management degree
but it was 2009.
so they're no jobs so I dug ditches for
a while until I figured it out
yeah so how did you start your company
yeah you figured it out that's not yeah
I know I mean I feel like I've told the
story so many times I hate to be boring
if anybody's ever seen this I've never
this is what happened
I worked for a company called Austin
bridge and Road and I was digging
ditches or cleaning off catch basins and
getting you know stuff for catch basins
is what catches the water under the road
and I did that for a while that job
ended so I moved to Baton Rouge and I
would wait tables at Texas de Brazil
and I would put up metal buildings or go
apply for jobs during the daytime
and what ended up happening was they
were building this Hospital job
and I went to a
once and the ladies like you can't see
the boss I'm like yes ma'am yes ma'am I
go back can I see is he is he available
he's like you you can't come and see the
boss well so
I think it was the third or the fourth
time I went
I ended up talking to her about on
her wall and her kids because she had
photos open this is a Job trailer and
construction site the hospital's not
done they're building it
and she goes you know what stay right
there
and I have my little resumes because I
go hand them out during the day trying
to get a construction job
and I had nothing on it by the way all
this all it was I played football and I
had a construction management degree but
in 2009 there was not as much work we
were in the recession so
oh grizzled 50 something year old white
man comes in because you Justin I'm like
yes sir he goes come with me so we go
back in the Job trailer plops down in
the seat
and he leans back and he's like and I'm
just like slide it to him right
he looks at it he looks at me and he
looks like he looks at me He Flops it on
the table and goes you mean to tell me
that you've come in here three or four
times I know about you coming in here to
talk to the boss to get a job on a 40
million dollar Hospital project and I'm
like yes sir
and he took a deep breath and he looked
at me goes I like that he gave me a
job boom got a job
and what I did
was I went to the bank you had to have a
net worth of ten thousand dollars and I
had read Rich Dad Poor Dad my junior
year of college we're on the way to play
Arkansas
and it was a bus trip it was short and
like I you know tried to get through it
right so I knew I wanted to have a
business I understood the quadrants as
as they would say like employee business
owner and gets to investor all those
things
and uh so what I did is I went to the
bank and I was like listen they're
paying me per diem
I can live off of that once you take my
whole check and put it in this other
account because I want to save up ten
thousand dollars because you had to have
a net worth you could have put my whole
family together it would have been
negative something you know what I'm
saying so I'm like let's leave them out
of it let me see let me see if you know
if I can save this money up and sure
enough after six months I you know I
saved the six excuse me ten thousand
dollars up and apply for my contractor's
license
and that was 13 years ago so and where
did you get this like drive from because
it doesn't sound like either of your
parents really it sounds like they
pushed you into business or anything no
no not at all yeah because it's like for
me it's
it's just expected that's like what
everyone does but for you it's so
interesting to hear when people come
from like
a background that maybe wasn't conducive
like the best place to grow up and they
still end up like crazy successful I
think what happens is some people
and or two of these people are sitting
here
some people see
what their atmosphere has to offer and
they follow it
some people like me
see their atmosphere and know what they
don't want to become
and it was just simply that for me
and then you have to think too hot
testosterone Young American red blooded
ambitious Sports background competitive
uh and I wouldn't even say I'm that
competitive really like I don't compare
myself to people ever ever ever and it's
not because I'm like super against it I
just don't feel that way it would be
disingenuous for me to be like I don't
compare myself to other people because I
love myself now I just really don't feel
that way I'm just I I do love myself and
for the you know
um
so I don't know exactly where it came
from in regards to like what sparked it
but I do quite enjoy it and I think
that's probably has something to do with
it and I also think it's a bigger risk
to have a really good job
and be capped out you know ever be to
fail I'd much rather fail I go bankrupt
tomorrow I would get a job that was
enough that when I got caught
working on my business they'd fire me
and I wouldn't care
I think a lot of people get caught in
that trap they get that really good job
and that mortgage has got to get paid
and if they lose that job they're
and I was just as happy in a shitty
apartment that I am in my place in Miami
or my new house in Dubai is going to be
you know so
I actually think it's harder for you
really I do I hear every day how I had
it very easy no I get that but it's
perception though yeah it's perception
like
I always say about about rich children
it's like being born in the zoo in
captivity let's say you're a lion you
get born in the zoo you get fed every
day the Zoo closes they kick you out
into the jungle but you don't know how
to hunt
and
for you it's it's the it's the Gap in
perception right so anything short of
being white trash from Louisiana I'm
doing better than I started for you to
even get to where your father got you
guys is a lot of work oh I will
not right I will not get to where my
father is but you do understand no I
don't want that life yeah so maybe for
you it's a freedom thing or something
else what is it what do you mean what
drives you
I'm interviewing you now oh my dad he
owns a software company
so nice like wrote the same amount of
people roughly like 200. yeah um he sold
it though so he doesn't anymore but but
I just
I would never see myself getting this
that big and if I did like I'd need
someone else to manage it because I just
I'm a woman I don't like managing people
it's I'm too agreeable you know are you
yeah
you need to hire a what you need
to hire a a oh yeah you're
the best especially one that loves you
yeah if you like you know how they say
behind every good man is a strong woman
Sometimes women are really good managers
I have women in very important
management roles so
toughen up or five on one
yeah I just I just think 200 people that
would be a lot I don't it's a lot but if
you under if you understand like scaling
and stuff like that you think about
people do it all the time tell me how do
you scale how do you scale yeah I don't
I don't know well systems
hiring systems okay understanding the
psychology of the it's a very long
conversation okay but we can we can have
a scaling conversation probably it's a
whole different show this is this is
like that's it it's long-winded it's not
a it's not a five second it'll be an
hour from now and you'll be like okay
well it was good talking to you
we can come back to to scaling yeah we
can come back
okay so you started your business um how
did you get into the red pill space
I would you consider yourself red pill
manosphere like what would you label I
wouldn't want to but I think it's an
inevitable that I can't get away from
it's like one of those things right
um
so
when I was in my 20s I dealt with a lot
of guilt around monogamy
and so I'd watch Richard Cooper or or
watch Rolo or I'd watch Myron and then
I found this Tate guy I'm like
that is saying I've
been saying for years that pisses people
off
and um
I joined the War Room
and I had to start I decided to start a
channel
because I've met Sterling
and Sterling's like yo you start a
channel and I'd always kind of wanted to
but I refused to let myself until I was
like a super liquid Millionaire right
because I I saw that there was a bit of
Deceit in in the online space no really
no no way the cap yeah I never I never
knew never
um
and so
I saw that and then I had the
conversation with Sterling and I went to
Miami and I was like dude I'm moving
here there's nothing else for me in
Louisiana
I I didn't feel alive anymore and that's
where your construction company is yeah
but I mean we're Nationwide oh okay yeah
we all 50 states and the Caribbean so
but that's what happened so I did that
and I'm with Sterling
Tate comes into town
tastes like yo come come eat dinner with
me
am I cool so I'll go see Andrew he's
like listen
I know you're starting a channel
and you could you could do this this and
this and I'm sure you you would kill it
but I think you got the magic already
got this thing going we're helping all
these people all these lives are
changing I'm doing this thing with the
real world
and these kids are making money like
we're boys like let's get closer and
like let's let's work together
and I kind of looked at it like NATO
you know what I'm saying okay it's like
I'll build all together but really we're
just like the same Army and uh so this
was you Tate Sterling and who else well
who was who was really hanging out over
over the years has been me tate Sterling
satorial shooter Jewel okay and T and of
course I'm really close to Luke
you know like when I go to buy I go to
see Luke Dylan Madden I go see so it's
just like being it's like being on the
football team again
you know and I thought back to the times
where I was happiest in my life
and it was absolutely college football
and then I started questioning myself as
to why
oh because all we did was hang out
together all the time lift weights do
the equivalent of making money whatever
that might be
um we always had each other's back we
went into Arenas together and like work
and I'm like oh
it's just like football no that's so
true because guys always like talk about
their college football days and I don't
I super don't I don't bring it like I am
not an uncle rico I actually take a lot
of pride in that
but what I do talk about is the
experience no but that's probably why
because when else in their life are they
gonna get never never also why I think
military guys have so much trouble when
they come home
you drive a million dollar tank
shooting you're basically Rambo all day
fighting for your country you have like
this deep rooted thing that you're proud
of that you're doing which is your
purpose at the time like us trying to
help young men with the real world in
the war room
and then you come home to like some
job and you got to bag groceries or like
stock a warehouse and drive a warehouse
forklift that I get it completely
and men are discur I think a lot of
times in relationships men are
discouraged from having male friends
like the woman gets jealous or the woman
starts nagging because I mean let's be
honest like guys guys get up to trouble
sometimes when they're with the I mean
in our in our view right like you know
so yeah he's like dude I killed five
people in Iraq and I got some
care and telling me to come home before
the street lights come on yeah yeah yeah
yeah I fought for it if it weren't for
me you wouldn't even live in this
country right or this country would be
run by somebody else you know you'd be a
war bride it's the craziest thing man
like people don't like I'll never
understand what it's like to be a
veteran I know this if I see one yes sir
let me open this door can I buy you that
beer and I do things same thing for
construction workers I do I do it all
the time if I see a construction Guy
online that you ain't paying for
bro I do it all the time because
people don't understand what it takes to
make this world go around
and that's something that I think that
as women like and particularly women
don't understand no and I'll tell you
because Gavin I started my channel
um reacting to like content so when I
started I would react Kevin Samuels role
like everyone I you know just just like
you I was on the other side right but I
was just just watching and people could
kind of see me go from like blue pill to
red pill in like real time and one of I
remember watching one of Kevin Samuel's
streams saying like you couldn't like
live without men and I'm like well I
mean can you just get an apartment and
like but I never thought about it in the
real matter-of-fact way yeah I didn't
think about it in the society way let me
ask you a question yeah
when I just pulled up with those
security guards Tate sent me those
mountains I want I want some right and
I'm walking towards you and I'm looking
at that construction site
all men oh man all men
amen
and if and if they're digging right and
if they don't Shore that correctly one
of them's down the hole and it collapses
woman won't die they might just leave
the man down there
it's an ugly ugly truth of the world
everything in this room
was built by a man
and you know what I realized too it's
like we almost give women these like
high paying like cushy jobs that I don't
think are as valuable in society as like
we think so it's like we almost have
these girls in these like tech jobs that
that I think are inflated to be honest
and I think tech jobs are inflated
to be fair yeah but I just see like
women start to think like we're better
than men a lot of the times and it's
just like well men and now I realize
it's like men literally run the world
they run the infrastructure of society
so it's like when do we ever talk about
that yeah in in a lot of ways it's
supported by women I would never take
anything away from women in the
workplace though my most important
employee is a woman in his body
Landslide and she makes well into six
figures I wrote her a thirty thousand
dollar bonus check at Christmas I just
took her to Florida with me like
woman's important I don't disregard
women's importance they're often
accountants they often do the payroll
they're often very organized they are
often very very good in negotiation
situations
I call them my Trojan horses
I'll get a phone call
hey Justin I got this job in Kentucky he
said this this and this I'm like and and
that he'll give it to us if we'll do it
for this I'm like cool tell him this and
when you do he's going to say this
when he does say that and call me back
she'll call me back she's like got it
all right cool Checkmate bye
women are disarming
so if I call that guy he think he's
automatically got his guard up with a
woman he put his car down
and you can get to a real conversation
about what makes sense and it's not a
dick measuring contest
men you know how I was telling you you
were being a girl earlier when we're off
the camera yeah when men are being like
that it's because their egos in front in
front of what actually needs to happen
to get it done but no him but it
actually makes sense right I mean you
talk about monogamy you're like yeah but
I couldn't do it you understand it you
personally you can't do it so for men
have the same thing it's on different
subjects right so when I talk about
scaling and I talk about is a long
conversation yeah
it's understanding all the Dynamics
involved and setting not only the
systems up but the calm lines up and
communication lines up in the right way
I don't call my men when they get in
trouble for not tying off on a building
I have Noelia call him and she speaks
very sweet to them in Spanish because if
I call them hey for kundo tough on the
roof
hey shut the up I'll fire you
where's the Noel because I don't want to
fire for kundo Noelia calls him okay I
do for you no problem
or the War I didn't have to fight that
war because I understand the dynamic you
know and it's not this sexual thing it's
just not a dick measuring contest
because if I call him I have to threaten
him
because he's like oh you know the boss
right the boss right well your
calls I do for you
it's a different game
so you started you said it was like NATO
the War Room
I say it's like NATO but I mean it was a
bunch of Brands coming together so I
think of more like Sterling had a brand
first right Sterling is very much
involved you know I have a brand but I
was always kind of on the on the team if
you will you know like I kind of started
off that way because I had that early
conversation with Andrew but
um yeah it's like it's like a bunch of
powerful people get together and make
something great
you know
um nothing else I'd rather do
than to be instead of and it's easy for
me to say right but I can look at these
other creators they're by themselves
and for that reason a lot of times all
they do is end up talking about
people
you see what I'm saying yeah and I'm not
I'm not trying to out anybody but I'd
much rather have what I have
the only reason I bring up the security
guard team and taking everything is
because he's like hey man
I want you safe in London I'm sending
people
other people in the space that work
alone talk they don't get that good
luck
you know
or it's just like family stuff like
I took his mom to lunch yesterday
you know it's like we're family bro how
is she doing she she's got to be a rock
she's a wonderful woman yeah wonderful
woman she did a great job clearly so
yeah all's good
um
so when when was that that you guys got
together that was three years ago yeah
around about three years ago okay
and tell me a little bit more about the
war room so you what do you guys do the
war room is a place where you go to
develop yourself in every way you get
new Consciousness you start to
understand how the world works on a
macro
and then you learn how to develop
yourself on a micro so there's many
events
um there's events about money and how to
run a business how to scale
there's events about
how to network with high level
individuals saturo runs a great event
called penetrating the elite
where you learn everything from Fashion
to the little things that a wealthy man
is looking for from somebody else so
give me an example like like this watch
are the cuff links so the watch matches
the the that's nice and the little like
just the little things are down to you
know he calls it a a wealthy man's
uniform okay you know it's the subtle
things in the tailoring the in the
inside of a jacket that you just might
see at a glance yeah I wouldn't know
this no you wouldn't know yeah I know
you never know like I can tell you're
well dressed but I would never look like
look at the well-dressed man can tell
the difference between a suit off the
rack and a suit that was tailored really
yeah yeah you can tell so you guys go
through things we do table etiquette
everything table etiquette everything
I'm telling you the event that Satoria
runs is a world-class event
everything from table etiquette how to
speak
to just everything eye contact
handshakes they practice handshakes at
that event it's very very important
wow this sounds great yeah it's called
making men
it's like if there's a woman version of
this that's the thing you know and I get
messages every day from women like can I
join the world of course you can't you
know it's it's not for that who are we
to tell you how to be a woman right but
one thing I think the red pill kind of
it's not that they get wrong but they
let the message come off the wrong way
is that
I don't think the red pill is against
women I think that if you really love
women you'll build strong men not
despite a woman but for women
and I think the red pill has helped my
relationships with men to be honest like
especially like my dad and my brothers
um like when you guys I listen to
something where they're talking about
how love or respect is to men as like
love is to women and it just like me and
my little brother
um I just used to like the more I like
didn't you know he's with little brother
so you don't always want to listen to
him or take his opinion you know because
you're like you're younger than me but
the more I would like respect his
opinion I realized like I got along
better with him better than everyone
else in my family because he's just a
bit of a headstrong you know
um and so I think if like if we can get
past the part where we're triggered and
really just like listen right it helps
us it helps us understand men better
100 agree and and particularly around
like dynamics of relationships uh it's
like like we were talking about before
the cameras came on again I hate to keep
bringing it up but monogamy yeah like
men and women don't understand each
other right there and if they did I
think less people go ahead yeah
uh I thought you were going to pull up
our chart oh we can't
but but it's it's so true is if men and
women could understand each other more
and redefine their definition of what it
looks like
um I think it would be much healthier
and I think we could see families again
for sure yeah you triggered me a little
bit last time you're on the show did you
good a little bit I was a little
triggered are you mad no no I was I
wasn't mad I'm never mad but it was like
when you were saying that my dad was
cheating I was like my dad wouldn't do
that like yeah but you're a girl you
don't want to believe it I'll tell you
this respectfully if I had to bet a
million dollars I would have to put it
on he did it at least once
because I know how men are right you
know what I'm saying and I also know
that the woman would not have had to be
attractive
just different yeah you know and it's
hurtful as it is and and I remember
because you told me that was my world
view and I'm thinking to myself you
shove your worldview up your ass I know
yeah just how they are and and I think
what really makes that tough is
one might be under the assumption that
had your father done that and I'm not
saying he did he would be a bad man I
would say
I would say he took care of his family
he provided for your mother and never
left her for a younger woman
took care made you an incredible person
made your brother a good person and out
supporting Society right
that's a one percent man just because he
got some on a Tuesday one time has
nothing to do with who he is and I think
Society that up they say there's
this great guy and he did very very good
but he slept with that one
actually
I agree with you yeah I think like
but
I think if my dad was in your position
and I think most men if they're in your
position or the position of like many
athletes or whatever where women are
like chasing them and hunting them down
I I don't think there's a lot of men
that would say no over like a 50-year
period so actually I agree with you no
chance so here here's the other thing
too is that you take a man that uses
monogamy and lo loyalty as a mating
strategy
you know look at a guy like me or my
friends and be like those guys are a
piece of baby I would never
no no no
women mistake a guy that can't get it
for loyalty big mistake people make big
mating strategy of more beta type guys
they're trading sexual exclusivity
for
something they can't get regularly which
is sex
and they give up all their research
resources for it
and they want to act like I'm a bad guy
but just before we turn this camera on I
showed you a woman that was throwing
herself at me
and what did you see me send her back
you said no in some way you showed it
you said a photo you sent her a photo of
her family boom now who's now
kids are so cute too
but you said you didn't judge her I was
like how do you not judge that I'm not
judging her I see it so much
I still have Facebook
okay
it's disgusting how many married women
hit on me on Facebook
it's disgusting
so
for me I
instead of getting mad at play ball I
understand how Burger me
yeah so you could you could get mad at
the game or you could play it I could
play and I just choose and look was a
woman attractive yeah
I just think like here's my thing number
one I don't wanna I don't want to sleep
on a bad conscience and I see those I
see those kids and I'm just like
ah I had that happen to me
yeah that happened to you oh yeah yeah
then then I'm watching my dad and my
stepdad roll around the grass in the
front yards why why
it's not like I'm not in abundance I'm
no I'm one of very few men that will
ever tell that woman no
and you saw what she said I'm like pick
somebody else she's like no I want you
our programming because if she was just
a she would just go somebody
it's not part of me it's it's across and
up right
it's exactly what is a prime example of
hypergamy
do you think women can ever be happy
with a guy that doesn't fulfill her
hypergamy like do you think that which I
think I think that if I was a normal guy
I didn't mean to cut your question off
good I don't want to answer the first
one if I were just some normal dude I
would not marry a woman that would not
commit to Leading social media
because it ruins it it ruins it look
back in the 80s my dad might have seen
one or two women
that were beautiful outside of my mom
and he might have seen them in a parking
lot one time and never saw him again
you know and so in that way it made
things a lot easier for people I don't
think it's easy for women because women
either they marry a normal guy
and they get flooded with every guy that
is statistically better than them in
some way and they are naturally
hypergamous by their Primal needs right
so I'm not out here saying like women
are
and then men
they go online and they're like me or my
friends and they get the selection of
all the women they want
and I might sleep with said person but
I'm probably not going to wife her up
because my inbox is full of it
you see what I'm saying so I don't think
it's easy for either side and then if
you're a normal guy
then you're really screwed because
you're not really kind of getting either
one of those
yeah like what do you think a normal guy
should do
to avoid being the husband
I don't lose I don't think it's about
about not being a husband or not no I
might avoid being because you could be a
husband without being married first of
all I'll say that okay if you have
children and you love somebody I believe
in love fully and also believe in family
fully so
if I had kids in a family if
I would take care of them fully
she would be retired
should have a very large house
and be set
if I was a normal guy
I would try to find a scenario where I
could be the hero because no man wants a
woman that he can't save from a castle
and dragon the reason you and your
brother get along more is because you
respect the fact that he's out there
working like you're you're showing more
respect to him
if the man cannot get admiration for the
hard work that he's doing it's no longer
worth it it's the beautiful thing about
love
I completely believe in love
if a man can't be with a woman where
she's like I really appreciate
everything you're doing to protect
provide you you are our hero
it's not worth it for the man
at all
it's simply not so what I would do
number one is I always say this is if
you were living in Indiana and you were
5 10. still get jacked
you can still work on your style you can
still get a damn good job or smart start
a small business
and you can be the man in your
little small town in Indiana
like the man
and then
ideally you wouldn't have you would have
a either a joint social media or none at
all
and that way you don't have to put your
wife in that position of of seeing all
the competition that's out there because
the only natural that's gonna
feel that way
so that's what I would do personally
and if she said you were controlling
a woman only calls a man controlling
when she doesn't want to be inside the
frame of that man
I've never had a woman call me
controller ever but hey
what's your Instagram that's so true
it's absolutely fun so true like a
girl's not gonna a girl no because all
she wants is to be with you saw that
other message I showed you yeah
especially when like the guy has all the
leverage it's like what you're gonna
argue and what and what but here's
here's the point of the matter though
let's say let's say I say yes to that
girl I sent the photo of her family too
I would have all the leverage then she
knows that damn good well when she's
going in women will go into a
relationship knowing the man's got all
the leverage that's what they want they
want to look up to the man
respect equals love of the woman they
want to respect you they can
hate you and still sleep with you they
could hate you and be in love with you
I've had many many many women
madly in love with me screaming I hate
you
it's closer to love isn't it yeah yeah
because indifference is what you should
worry about if you're a man
oh true yeah
so true you worry about the ex-boyfriend
that we talk about not the one that we
that we don't exactly yeah that's what
you should be worried about
and still being friends with him on
Facebook is
so is it controlling or do I love you
enough to not put these things in front
of you
why would I send my girl to the club you
can send a good girl to a club in Miami
and she'll up
she'll get drunk I come through start
talking a little next thing you
know boom
and she won't tell me that she's got a
boyfriend back home oh single girls trip
it's that dickhead's fault that sinner
our letter
and if she's truly in love with him and
she's like hey Sally wanted me to go on
a girls trip and he's like you ain't
going on a girls trip come with me she
don't want nothing in the world than
your time
especially if you're on your purpose and
you're busy and you're working a lot
truly not faking working but really
working she wants nothing in the world
but to be with you she's truly in love
with you genuine desire
and so
when that's not the case then I think a
man has a word about men worry after the
Sexes or after somebody's already
cheated
men should worry
when she's liking photos that she
shouldn't be liking it's like the small
or like can I go on a girls trip
just her asking
either you're going to have the educator
on the subject or you need to have a red
flag
I was going to say I do think a lot of
girls don't really think about it
because we're in a culture that like
encourages it and I will say this like I
do know girls that I would say are good
girls but
when I say no like I wouldn't go on a
girls trip they're like they're like
they're like why like they don't they
it's it doesn't compute because the men
have never been told this right a lot of
men have never been told don't let your
girl exactly and that's another reason
to join the War Room yeah because you're
getting this Consciousness on number one
how competitive it actually is these
guys think they're competing in their
friend groups
dude if you're competing in your friend
group first of all you don't have any
friends real friends I'll bring
dude I will take my girl and I'll leave
her at Tate's house for the weekend with
my bank card
I'm not worried about it not coming back
high in any way how I got it like you
would never and neither would I and even
any and you learn about your friends in
a couple ways women and money
number one like I don't even want a
friend that's not abundant in both of
those
why well think about it
you got two guys
been friends 20 years one of them gets
married
he goes over to the house all the time
hangs out
the wife and the husband start having a
rocky ship of it they get divorced the
first person she's gonna try to focus
him
and if he has not done his work as a man
to be in abundance enough abundance to
tell a woman no as you just saw me do
then he's gonna sleep with her
and then he ruined a 20-year
relationship
with the only friend he probably has
over 30 minutes
value values
and ethics come long before you actually
need them
so if that guy was taking care of his
business he would have been in enough
abundance to tell that woman to kick
rocks so much so that he would have
easily traded out the sex
for how proud he was of the honor that
he showed to his friend
and many men cannot do that and many
friendships Get Wrecked
over a divorce or a breakup that ends up
with some guy
his buddy over he's been friends
with him for 20 years because he doesn't
work hard enough on himself to have
women of his own
and so no I don't trust a man that
doesn't get women and I certainly don't
trust a man that doesn't have money
because it will come up and he will
you not because he's a bad man because
he's a desperate man
what do you mean it will come up
so if if you're with your buddies and
a money situation comes up or it could
be as simple as How come every time we
go out I catch the bill and nobody else
helps
you know or hey man I need a loan or all
these other things or if you go into a
business with somebody you find out
around money for sure
and women I think women probably come up
even more
I was just thinking about the money
thing because that I I that switched for
me how many times you cover the bill
with your friends
no I had a friend like steal from me I
had to like yeah it was actually yeah I
that's what I was thinking when you said
that I was like wow that did happen but
you have to pre-qualify now yeah you
know and one thing I pre-qualify with is
money women
you know because if you go off take a
piss mm-hmm
Sterling Cooper goes to take a piss and
we're at a restaurant the first thing I
do is look at the girl he's with and say
how the did you get Sterling Cooper
first thing
like that's just how we run our offense
you know
um
in regards to money
same thing like I don't I don't want to
think that I'm going to pick up every
Bill the biggest game that we play
between the five of us that I hang out
is who can act like they're going to
take a piss and pay the bill behind
everybody's back gotcha like
that's I literally do it all the time
I'll go to do it
and somebody would have already done it
30 minutes ago or vice versa
and like that's the kind of stuff you
want to do with your boys
you know or being degenerate riding
through the mountains and supercars and
like those types of things or if you
don't make a ton of money
you know maybe you go on a hunting trip
or or do whatever I'm not on
that I've had that life it's wonderful
there's a fulfilling life out there I
think social media makes a lot of people
unhappy
because it's all the gap between
expectation and reality that's what I
think happiness is just the gap between
expectation and reality
and that's also why I find a lot of
women are unhappy
if that woman that sent me that message
that I showed you
she were not on social media
she would not be comparing me to her
husband
she would not be comparing her life to
my life and for that reason she wouldn't
be trying to Monkey branch
she wouldn't know who you were that's
right and she'd be happy or she would
she would have met me because she came
on that project
but
wouldn't matter because there'd be no
follow-up there'll be no follow-up never
see him again it'd be like 1980s right
right I saw this guy on top guy that son
of a was handsome nice house was
that a minute
no way to get in touch for sure
and that's why you won't date any girl
seriously that won't come off of social
media
or at least I have the password yeah
yeah yeah yeah why would you no I think
that makes sense right and I think a lot
of times like men are told they can't
have standards for everything but it's
like with heat with you guys what is it
you'll just move on to the next yeah
easy easy and they know that and so it's
not even it's not even a Power Trip
thing to me it's like okay am I gonna
leave this or are you going to lead this
because if you're going to lead this
You're Gonna Leave This with another man
but here's here's a news flash for you
when that other man lets you lead you're
going to lose respect for him and then
you will be calling me
do you think women can ever be happy
leading relationships no you've never
seen one
no a woman leading the relationship
I think that's disingenuous to Nature
truly and I don't mean that
disrespectfully women are just as
important as men women are equal to men
it's a it's a stay in your lane kind of
type thing it's it's like what I said
before we were kind of like talking
about women in tech companies I'm like
oh no women are very important in
business but they're important in what
they do like God gave you guys
superpowers
yeah but I think a lot of times like
what I was getting at is like men will
always run the infrastructure of society
like if our jobs go away tomorrow
tomorrow Society will still run we're
mad at some women's jobs
yeah of course yeah yeah but if women
stop having babies Society is also over
yeah but if men stop killing women
pregnant it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but
um
there's no there's no reason to say one
is less than the other they're just
clear facts right you understand what
I'm saying but they're like
controversial now
but it shouldn't be it's very it's very
cut and dry as clear as day
I don't think it is I well okay to the
average person we're in a penthouse
right now right yeah multiple cranes
throughout London I can guarantee you
there's not one woman
not only not in the crane but on the
ground doing the work there's not one I
agree it's just a matter of fact thing
no I see I agree with you but I mean I'm
saying like I don't think regular people
think about this stuff like regular
young people like they go through
Society thinking the pay Gap is real
they they go through Society thinking
women are oppressed they go like they go
through life literally believing these
things and I know because I talk to them
but that's as long as time when there
were Kings and Sultans are big up on the
hill in the castle they would send down
the people to scream War famine blah
blah scare people really well yeah
why because it's the same thing as Fox
and CNN
trick all the stupid people the Sheep
they call it the one percent for a
reason
we need these people to be stupid a lot
of the times or at least you know what
they're not even stupid they just don't
look for themselves
especially Karen's
you know they want to I call myself a
Karen sometimes
I can't call you Karen we're not friends
um feel free to call me an at
any time but I am can I take pride I
think Society needs Karen's I do too I
can see that if the party's loud next
door I'm calling I'm calling it yeah
I like HOAs because I don't want your
car on the road I paid a million
plus dollars for my house to keep the
transmission in in the garage
yeah I'll get it
um
men and women need each other
there's an agenda for whatever reason
to push them apart I personally think in
the western world it's a tax thing
also if you look at technology
the more technology comes around
the more I feel that women
are going to be able to do jobs that
either didn't exist before but you get
the same result with technology you
might not need the back and the shovel
anymore
or maybe some things are less dangerous
than they used to be because of the
circumstances of Technology Etc I don't
particularly feel a need to take away
credibility from women
I feel that's a very short-sighted way
to look at it I'm not a feminist in any
way in fact I think feminists are
ruining women
along with social media and the
that we let women do on social media I
don't think they're happy
I think the happiest women on the planet
look up to a man that is their hero
that they're very very proud
to call their husband
and they want to be inside his frame
because they have true genuine desire
for him
whether he has to beat social media to
do it or there's not a social media
there so he's just beating a small town
doesn't matter but I do think the
happiest women are having children
supporting a man really believing in him
and being proud of him and everything he
does to kill himself for that family
all of us believe in family the War Room
believes in family Tate Sterling
satorial Tristan we all believe in
family
is very misconstrued
you know our beliefs in that area but I
can tell you now we all believe in
family and I think the happiest women
and the women that are in our lives feel
that way about us so
I think
I think it's going to get ugly before it
gets better you think it'll get
that a lifetime
after a lifetime at night yeah
well I think harines are going to come
back for sure her Maureen what is that
we have multiple wives like openly oh
yeah is that what you do
I might build one it's a local life goal
that I've never said out loud I
definitely could do it how many you want
it's about how many you can manage
because when you say Harem right you for
me like I said I believe in love right
so I'd want to care for the person like
like truly care about them but I've
never been I can't I've never fallen in
love with two women at once
so I don't know if that's possible
really yeah
I've never I've never fallen in love
with somebody like two people at one
time
you know so then how would you do this
so maybe maybe you're not maybe sense
maybe you're sort of monogamous no sort
of it sounds like a little bit about
love at least emotionally emotionally
yeah I think so so far some guys say
they can love multiple women at the same
time so you're more monogamous I've just
not experienced it right yeah you know
because I mean how many times you fall
in love in your life three four times
Maybe
you ever had lightning strike twice I
haven't and that's the point I'm making
and that's just me being honest now I
could tell a I'm in love with her
you know to keep her around
oh well if the tree falls in the woods
and nobody hears it
you know
but
you know so far in my life I've not I've
not fallen in love twice
what do you think is the biggest lie
that feminism tells women
what do they tell women
what do you think they tell women
oh what do I think oh I got strong
opinions but I but I'm here to interview
you well no I guess I mean it's about
defining what they're telling them
that they can do everything a man can do
or that they number one I'd say is that
they don't need men
let's keep it real you definitely need
men
and they're just the strongest man
this will probably be controversial for
me to say but if men want to enslave
women
they could do it
I mean physically stronger in every way
if they wanted to like obviously that's
a stupid thing to do I don't support
that but like men do run the situation
so the fact that they think that women
don't mean men it's like that apartment
example like what did you do if you
didn't have a man oh you get an
apartment yeah but not if he didn't
build it right not if he didn't keep
like so men invent build and maintain
everything in society
so
there's that and then there's also I
think there's a lack of appreciation for
men especially good men that just put
their nose down and do a nine to five
every day and really want to love and
support their family
why do you think that is
social media
mostly
they're out there telling women
that they deserve so much more and
deserve is a very
open word like it's a it's it can be
it can be many many things
and I think that it gives them a little
bit of a
self-entitlement
and the lack of understanding of what it
takes to really make the world go around
the car they get in
the cell phone the mall all these things
built and invented and maintained by men
and you have a guy he's a plumber and he
works really really hard and he makes
decent money he can provide give a home
but now that's not enough somehow he's
given his entire life force to it
right
I hope no plumbers are watching this
show
um but it it's that in its entirety it's
like I don't think women quite
understand sometimes and actually it's
not even that they don't understand it's
that they buy the there's not
enough people out there telling them no
that's not true
you do need men around you do have to
have men for society to work I don't
think enough women just they don't get
the other message they get the women are
paid less which is statistically not
true
it's not true no I know
I'm so tired of that stat they were
fighting they're fighting for a value
they're not giving
was it was it the soccer team that had
to split their money
and I'm in women like I I literally took
women's sports to almost the high I
would have went pro if I didn't this
YouTube didn't take off right so
it's like if we don't make money it's
because we're not as entertaining like
get over it people don't want to watch
you yeah yeah the only I was joking the
other day I watched LSU win the national
championship in basketball mostly
because I was pulling for that little
girl from Iowa
hello Caitlyn girl the one you didn't
see it right is good see this is
yeah even me an athlete I know the
matter is why in the hell does anybody
want to watch women's basketball I don't
want to watch a bunch of layups
it's boring it's not fun to watch so it
was just like one of those situations
and
and no and it's just like people that
pull pull
the race card or the feminist car or
whatever card there's the well it's just
value it's a value Exchange
you know we have a woman vice president
what are you talking about women are
oppressed
the out of here
you know and is she even qualified for a
job who who knows right and the it's
always the laziest girls that complained
about the pig app never the women that
work hard it is never the one that's the
ugliest women that are the most
feminists
beautiful women how many beautiful women
feminists do you know
you want a life hack be a beautiful
woman feminist I bet you'd go to the
Moon
you know I do I do know quite a few but
they're young and they won't be
beautiful much longer with their life
choices if I'm being honest
well I'll tell you what's gonna happen
they're gonna get married to some sump
yeah and be the leader in the
relationship and then they're gonna text
one of them guys I'm not gonna say no
okay I'll tell you a little red pill
thing I learned from the show okay okay
what I would notice is the feminists
that would come on the show and they'd
be arguing with someone like Destiny is
Destiny a feminist
you know uh both I guess if we're gonna
be technically no shade to Destiny yeah
seems like a nice guy you know um nice
enough but I think technically he would
be both uh if we're gonna you know be
technical here but but
um when feminists do come on the show
they'll argue with like a more
conservative guy
I always try to they're always flirting
with them after
absolutely yeah even if they're arguing
also it'll be that like I'll see them
and I'm just like I thought you hated
him like no they don't yeah but here's
why because girls only hit the boys they
like at recess
oh that's true that's 100 True tell me
more of these like red I love these like
analogies you keep giving me that's just
how I like that yeah
yeah so
that's just it though it's like I don't
and again no disrespect but I don't
listen to what women say listen to what
they do
that same girl I was telling you how
they can love you and be screaming at
you I hate you I wish I didn't love you
that girl loved you more than anybody
and as long as you don't take her from
where she is to scorn you're good
because scoring is like a rejection
thing
that's what creates anger
but if they if they're still in it
you know and as long as they're still
texting you I hate you you just
translate to I love you and I
can't quit thinking about you I'm not
listening to what she says I'm watching
what she's doing
and men don't get that the average man
doesn't get that that's why I should
joined the War Room you know not because
we're sitting there talking about about
bad about women I'll tell you a group in
the war room that I think is very
impactful in a way is called
relationships with loving loving
relationships with women there was some
along that it's a very kind room just
helping guys find the right frame it's
not talking badly about women like the
like the media talks about Andrew
it's like Hey listen if you really
really love her you're gonna have this
Frame because this Frame is going to
allow you to keep the relationship going
for a very long time that's the
beautiful thing
what what is frame to me frame is having
the lines and holding them very strongly
and being in a position for her to look
up to you and want to be inside that
frame because you've created a scenario
in your life where you can have a woman
that has true genuine desire for you and
for that reason she wants to be inside
your frame she doesn't want to go on the
girls trip she wants to be with you if a
woman truly loves you she wants your
time more than anything
more than anything in the world she
doesn't she's not worried about your
money
money's a part of frame but that's not
what she's after it's all the things
that collectively come together that
make you the man that she wants to get
saved by
and when I say saved I'm using it more
hypothetically like Castle on a dragon
there's there's imagine imagine a
princess up in a tower right
and she has the option to have a strong
competent
dominant man and I mean dominant like
masculine like frame wise right
come save her or some simp that is gonna
say hey maybe we can climb down together
and fight the fight the dragon together
or does she want to do this as I slit
the dragon's throat you're coming with
me
bro what horse she gonna get on Cowboy
you know what I'm saying it's not it's
not hard you know and men are outwardly
signaling their ability to do such Why
did Indians have feathers
I can hunt getting this teepee
and we're constantly signaling why do we
drive Lamborghinis
money
signal
well it's like a money signal right it
is yeah but why does why do all the
animals in the animal kingdom have all
these elaborate colors and things that
they do it's a signal ah
it's just that simple so there's a
mystery method it was like peacocking
right mystery method I don't know much
about pickup what I have found my
opinion of pickup is is that it's more
learning how to manipulate than it is
being the guy
I I wouldn't say that I have great game
I say I have incredible signaling though
and I think that
one massively comes before the other
it's like the tip of the icebergs game
right now I can be really Charming in a
conversation but I'm not very texter
mostly because I can't be bothered to do
it you're pretty Miami question mark
right you know I don't give game advice
I saw a guy made a hit video about me
the other day I said that and he like
clipped it he's like this is why being
rich up your game bro I get more
than you let's not
you know what I'm saying I trip over it
and I think the goal is to absorb women
not chase them aggressively
I did think about hiring somebody at one
point just to send like cold DMS because
I'm lazy and I don't give a you
know hey hey hey and just see what bites
because Myron always talks about a
numbers game like just experiment-wise
right but if you have all these girls
chasing after you anyway why why do it
because you'd only go after like
straight tens uh straight tens it'd be
like a very targeted very targeted this
is my type this this and this there's
some examples only this you know who's
your oh celebrity crush don't have one
none there's no no celebrity that you
would like pick above all like if you
could like they would send the message
to would be the first message I think I
watch enough TV
oh come on I'm trying to think
I don't have anybody in my mind
but I'll tell you this
my chess guy
that I expect there to be everything
and I actually once I meet somebody I
really like somebody I have a
conversation with like I like intellect
truly
um
I should be able to give you a celebrity
crush I don't think I have one if you'd
have asked me when I was in like 10th
grade I would have told you Angelina
Jolie probably
oh she's beautiful yeah she's stunning
natural beauty
um but now I think she's a yeah
yeah she's a little crazy I do think
Brad Pitt is the most handsome man to
ever live
don't argue with me I'm right I'm super
right but I don't have a crush on him
yeah that's so I'd pick but yeah who
would you pick
um there is it
no I don't want to say
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um no because the problem is if I say
people sometimes I like I interview them
later so like then they'll clip me okay
um you talked about
um when a woman becomes scorned yeah can
you tell me what happens when a woman
becomes scorned well I think the first
thing they would do is try to hurt you
back
you know
so you know you might have a woman say
oh you have a small dick or you know
they might try to your friend you
know things like that
um they might go get a Revenge body they
might try to do things on social media
upset you I don't actually deal with it
very much I don't think I've scored a
woman since College
I was just wondering because I'm doing
this documentary right now on um the
court system in the UK so I'm
interviewing a lot of men um that were
basically screwed over ah they'll do it
with children
for sure
and child support and alimony yeah but a
lot of these men it like came out of the
blue like one guy interviewed he had
they had one fight in seven years and
then one one day she was just done and I
was just curious for him because he
didn't see the signs that came before
what actually happened
and and that was the point I was trying
to make earlier but it's the Small
Things in frame that you have to catch
but most men don't have it in their
Consciousness oh yeah she's just going
to Vegas to hang out with the girls
really
oh so to them it's out of the blue but
it really it really isn't I interviewed
one he said he'd still get married again
I was like what
but to me it's not about it's not about
the marriage thing I'll never get
married on paper right
but I will be a loving father husband
no problem
that used to trigger me too when I first
got in the manosphere well you're wrong
I was wrong I was but why why what was
your perception at the time uh my
parents were married and I saw the value
in marriage and you know
I I never really heard of anyone not
legally getting married right so also
you saw a very winning structure
all right so let's do your life in my
life okay
some of my first thoughts are screaming
and infidelity and violence and divorce
and then divorce court and then having
to go see a child psychologist to see
who I'm going to end up living with and
like that my mother spent seven of
the nine months pregnant with me
on a couch at her friend's house because
she was cheating on my dad while she was
pregnant yeah
sorry um well she's pregnant
seven of nine months laying on a couch
on her girlfriend's couch because my dad
kicked her out for cheating
he married her twice he married the same
woman twice
divorced her
she came back
because that's what happens that's what
happens these normal women
they think because you sleep with them
that they're going to Monkey Branch over
to you they get pumped and dumped and
they're like oh I'm out in the
streets oh well I know I can go back to
him
takes her marries her again
whereas your your relationship with
family and marriage and your father and
your mother is is about as
picture-perfect as it could be they're
still together yeah unheard of unheard
of your your dad is a one percent in
every way so
you saw something that's probably one in
a thousand and I'm probably under
shooting
the statistic there
because you literally believe in your
father so much to this day you think he
never cheated
deal you know I love that for you yeah I
love that for you and I'm not even here
to argue that with you at all I'm just
simply saying you saw the best possible
outcome in the scenario yeah well I
think there was two things I didn't
realize and I don't think most people
realize how much of a risk it is for men
to get married massive and you know I'd
heard of men getting screwed over and
divorced but like in a blue pill
perspective you're like well you know
she had the kids so maybe she's oh a
little bit is what is what you think
until you really think about and you're
like wait she worked too what are we
yeah it's not it's not the same 1920s
structure anymore we're not the same
type of women and I also didn't realize
how hard it is for men to get access to
their kids
yeah that was the biggest thing for me
it's not even about money it's like I've
talked a guy after after guy who lives a
mile from his kid and hasn't seen them
in months
and it's just like she can do that with
one call and no pre repercussions my mom
did that to my dad that's why we went to
the custody court so many times wow
in fact she would have got them
somebody died in his family inherited
ten thousand dollars he was just about
had he was out of money with the lawyers
and he used that last 10 grand
to fight it
and that's I mean and look he
he we did not spend a lot of time
together growing up but I appreciate
that from him and that's why I like I
did the other day I paid his house off
he's a good man
and he was born in a certain time in
history
where the cards were super he didn't
have Rolo tomasi
he didn't have Cooper he didn't have me
he didn't have tape he didn't he didn't
understand he was doing exactly what he
saw work which was his my grandfather
was a World War II tail Gunner came home
bought a bunch of land farm cotton built
houses
and his his father was masculine it was
dominant
he would literally be sitting at the
table his tea would not run out before
my grandmother was up pouring it back I
mean literally
cotton tablecloths cotton napkins the
the table was set she cooked every meal
three times a day they'd come in off the
off the farm and eat lunch and go right
back out in the field he saw this thing
work
and so he bought into it much like you
he married one for the streets
and it wrecked him it really did it
wrecked him he married her twice it
financially him up he was never
going to be rich already it kept him
poor when I would go see him in the
Summers
he lived in
God it must have been a 900 800 square
foot house 50 a month for in the middle
of some cotton fields
in Rayville Louisiana like he he never I
mean she made him poor for a very long
time
and all she had to do was keep accusing
him things like molesting my little
sister like crazy
you know and here we are consequence and
there's no consequence it's like women
that like charts say that people don't
well and what I learned was and you
might already know this but I didn't
realize Family Court isn't about
evidence
so it's on the balance of probabilities
it's not based on like evidence and all
they have to do is convince the judge
and so it's like they're not even
getting their right to like face their
accuser their right to a fair trial oh
no so what they will talk about is the
papers a lot in in that life our whole
childhood was wrapped around the papers
and how old are you me like back then on
the very young sub 10. wow so eight sub
seven like young young when all this was
happening so we'd have to go to the
courthouse for these things but they
would go in the in the judges Chambers
and have conversations it was more like
that you're exactly right they had way
more of a relationship with the judge
than you would normally have in like a
normal trial the judge is the guy he's
going to referee this thing no they knew
this guy judge strong uh even I know his
name I'm I'm in my 30s now and it was
his name was Joe Strong he's a long time
dead
but it was in Rayville
and um yeah it was just one of those
situations where Rayville Louisiana
nowhere town but
it's very very much like that because
what are you gonna do so she accuses of
him of molestation they're gonna ask my
five-year-old sister
like
even if they didn't convict him or they
didn't
if even if they didn't conclude that he
did that what what consequence does she
have for doing that nothing nothing but
I'm a big proponent of if you accuse
somebody
and they're found not guilty you should
get the same time that he would have got
I agree with you a thousand percent
anybody with common sense would
you know and if you don't
call the police within at least 48 Hours
it should get thrown out immediately
because then it's just oh you regret it
like call us but at least make a report
you know why you think about it but
only I think I could see is maybe like
childhood stuff
you know what I mean like because yeah
yeah I completely agree with that
because then you're you're in this you
know everybody that takes care of you
you're gonna get kicked out but it's
still even tricky with that because it's
like
that what how whatever you know it's
it's not really a black and white you
know no it's not because I was I was
like my first my my first thought was
going to well what about kids that were
abused but then my second thought as
well that seems like a system that could
get abused really easily too easily and
I'm sure it already does
um I don't know much about like accusing
someone of something years ago I don't
know how that works but I don't either I
don't either it's a sad situation but
um it certainly still happens
so it's just one of the it's just one of
those things that I feel like as Society
I don't I think in 200 years they're
going to look back at where we are right
now
and they're gonna be like
wow they were kind of in the Stone Age
kind of like how we look at you know the
Middle Ages let's say Kings and Queens
I'm like oh you know they didn't even
have Netflix they'll be like those
people
they used to they killed Princess Diana
in a tunnel and like got away with it
you know what I'm saying you know what
I'm saying yeah like that kind of stuff
I think they'll be like wow you know
they really were crooked back then
social media they'll say the same thing
about elections and people getting muted
and all kinds of things they'll be like
there was a Power Trip Do You Believe In
The Deep state
educate me
um the major I mean some people call it
the Matrix the Deep State like what is
that for us yeah I think there's
probably some pretty wild WhatsApp group
chats okay where you're like if you saw
the lineup in that group chat you'd be
like you they can do anything they
want
yeah
okay tell me more I simply that that's
it yeah and I'll couple that with I
think that Elon getting a hold of
Twitter is one of the best things happen
for Humanity in a very long time
would have took just that you know
because at least there's going to be
some kind of free speech now so I
respect I respect that I was really
excited when he when he picked up
Twitter
so he's funny too he's tweeting yeah
he's cool bro I put I put him up there
like Trump and stuff like that like I
really appreciate Elon yeah
um tell me about your friendship with
Tate
what would you like to know
um how's he doing
he's doing well he's doing well you
can't break take
so
any man that does anything great in this
world will come out under some trials
and tribulations and fire and he's just
going through his
I have nothing but confidence in Andrew
I believe in him fully love him miss him
you know it's great being able to hear
it from him
and um
I suspect nothing but good things to
come in fact I think this is going to do
nothing but 10x is influence
and for that and for that reason I don't
think there's anything to worry about I
also would never put negative energy in
there about somebody I care about so
much
we put good things into the universe you
know it's not a law of attraction thing
it's just just putting it out there
so I know everything's about I know
they're not gonna be able to prove it
everything they're accusing him is
ridiculous was completely awesome Oh you
mean the six foot three kickboxing
millionaire with all the Lambos that's
as smart as any person you'll ever meet
I found out they were luxury shopping
and I was like
you were held captive to go luxury shops
it's laughable well and I tell oh my
gosh I couldn't even imagine this story
all right I think about this if I had to
tell my dad oh Dad I went to Romania did
Cam work for this this multi-millionaire
luxury shop got to
he drove me in these sports cars I and
now I decided I was coerced yeah or I
don't know the official it sounds like
you were in love with James Bond and it
didn't work out the way you wanted it to
that's what it said you know I'm not
going to act like I know every fact from
the case but the way it sounds it sounds
crazy I'll give you a fact from the case
okay there's cameras all over that house
why aren't they just using that
when you walk into Andrew's house
there's the screen and shows the cameras
for the whole property he's got a
security team there all that camera
footage just put that out
just put that out why don't they that's
so weird why would they
they haven't they have they literally
have
him had him in jail he's just been
released as We Know
but he's under house arrest right now
for for
he doesn't have he does not have to
force himself upon a woman
Andrew's biggest problem Tristan's
biggest problem is what woman to choose
I can tell you that for a fact I've just
been around too much
you know Jules been around him too much
that's Jules job is to find these things
in people and find these in Congress
like he's an investigators has been for
years a very very high level Jewel
himself would know
and he comes out openly and tells you
look I've been around these guys more
than anybody
what do you say what do you say to the
people that say well maybe he just says
another side that you didn't know
that would be like owning a grocery
store and going to steal food
why
that you know I'm saying like let me
tell you something women is something
that both of those boys are in abundance
of for sure I told them there's no
reason to do it I said I was like you
should make a website application for
girls I was like doing that for my my
harem yeah I'm gonna make an application
process Supply Here imagine if the teeth
no they'd have to have a full-time staff
to sift through it
full-time staff
what I would need a staff to sift
through it I tell you right now whatever
my staff would have to be they'd have to
have 10 more
there's no way they don't have
to do it well and it just goes back to
like the no accountability it's like for
the women it's like one they're not why
wouldn't you accuse them it's your only
payday I mean did you see the text
messages that came out talking about how
much money they're gonna make and
they're going to be famous and all these
things
yeah meanwhile these women have not been
charged they it's right there in the
text
we're going to be famous hahaha
and then Brittany Greiner
goes to Russia
brings weed admits that she's done a
crime and we trade what like some kind
of arms dealer or some for her the
what
he's in jail saying he's not into the
joke and all the girls are saying he did
he never did this
and now all of a sudden the girl power
has gone away now you're not smart
enough to think for yourself
well and the other thing is it
takes what 30 and mid 30s 36 36. people
don't just do things out of the blue
they have a pattern if he really was
that guy there would be girl after girl
after girl coming out and that's a
really easy thing though too right
because once like if these girls will
jump on a gravy train I'm saying prove
it
prove it you were literally with him
making stories you think when you went
on that yacht you were posting all these
stories with him you weren't sleeping
with him a I can't even imagine
telling my dad look at that I'm like do
they have fathers or brothers in their
life like what do they say to them well
first of all their fathers and their
brothers are like will you bring them to
the house you know
what bro guys are such Fanboys for
Andrew yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
I've seen girls I've literally had girls
reach out to me because their brother or
co-worker watches my and they'd be
watching it at work and they'll be like
hey I work with this guy he's a huge fan
but really they're just sliding in my
DMs
and then they fly
you understand what I'm saying like
they'll be like oh he loves you he loves
you and then the girl will want to meet
me because of it I'm telling you right
now Andrew cannot message back all the
women that are messaging him
he does not need to go out and take sex
from a woman he's the most asinine
thought on the planet well and if this
is happening to him how many average
guys does this happen to you every day
it's like oh yeah you know what I mean
like like thank God Tate has cameras to
prove it like he has a legal team like
he has money and resources but what
happens to the average guy that has no
camera I'll tell you exactly I got
everything's going through it right now
went on date with a girl
they had drinks they had sex she decided
after the fact that she doesn't like it
she's been kind of bending him over a
barrel ever since
so it ends up having to placate to that
game
well what happened to him is he in he
told me like three weeks ago
but it's it's going on it's like so like
trying to make her happy you know
whatever it is and it's disgusting
when did she file the police report she
didn't
she had regret
and she told him that she didn't
know what she was doing or whatever
which she did look when a woman
goes and meets a man and goes start
getting face drunk
they know what they're going to do
especially when they go home with them
you know and they're both drunk and
that's the craziest thing to me about it
it's like they both get drunk they both
do it
but it's almost laughable to think what
if he would be like okay now I'm gonna
I'm gonna sue her for rape because I
wasn't consent because I was under the
influence you get laughed at a
Court
it's a double standard completely
so
it's a it's a tricky thing the good
thing that Andrew has in his favor is
number one that he's completely innocent
number two that he has full evidence
number three is very clear that he
doesn't need to do these things in order
to get that part of his life handled
I have no concern I have no concern
whether he's innocent or not I just have
concern or whether he's going to get a
fair Shake in the end that's actually my
only concern
and why do you think there's this huge
animosity towards him like what why he's
just a man talking on the internet we
triggers people he's polarizing for a
reason often say you're like oh
you know
you're trying to be like dude I will
never be like like I the things he is
willing to say or where he'll go like
I'm not polarizing in that way
um I I just think
he's gotten enough attention and the way
that they clip his stuff gets in front
of the right people particularly
feminist and people that want to not
like him
and
it's just a very small group of people
that are really loud and obnoxious about
it it's just like the same people that
throw bricks through buildings and
protest it's a very small group of
people that make a bottle a lot of noise
but the truth of the matter is is that
like I've said before he's super
innocent
and so it's just going to be about
whether he gets a fair shake at it or
not
that's the
I realized when I got on YouTube I was
like they can clip you to make you look
like you said something you did not
say
like at all no absolutely and I'm just
like like even with um they were trying
completely out of context yeah and
there's one interview
um they were going so hard at him for
saying like he he'd rather be with a 19
year old than a 26 it was something like
that yeah no and and yeah and I was
like I'm 26 I'm not offended like who
duh yeah duh like I could say the same
thing with a 36 year old and a 26 year
old that's not rocket science that men
like younger women right but if you're
going to be TR like and I'm 20 like I'm
like I could be triggered by that but
you know but they're just only the
cheaters
I told you it's not cheating if you know
the deal no I know I know
how is it what is it like for you guys
as girlfriends what do you mean like
I just can't imagine listen clearly
awesome
I'm gonna get jealous do they get mad
like every woman gets jealous and gets
mad and it's like is a woman in such
reality or not or
in a lot of situations so okay look at
her like this
thank you
men get married
all the time
they pull both the families in they
promise
in front of God and everybody to do
their best to give her the best life
they can
but then they come home pop open a beer
play video games
and live a life that's mediocre at best
give her none of the Finer Things in the
world she never gets to travel she
doesn't get to see anything she doesn't
feel secure she's also working a
full-time job
who's the
because I'm telling the truth from the
job
giving a woman an experience that very
likely she's not ever had will never
have elsewhere
and being completely honest and
loving and caring and all the other
things
and at the same time being dominant
masculine we go back to the
you know situation where a woman would
much rather have a man take the lead
doing all of those things right
which girl is getting the worst deal
because the truth of the matter is that
guy that comes home and Pops that beer
open he will still cheat on that woman
if he had the opportunity
and that's again I'm not doing anything
that any other man would not do if he
could
and that was the turning point for me
with the cheating thing was I realized
that even my dad who's a great man if he
had women throwing themselves I I think
even the and I think best man in the
world the best man in the world and I
think some men don't put themselves in
that situation
let me preface that this though had your
father been in position where he was
getting women thrown to him if he would
have every now and then slept with one
of those women but still came home
tucked you in gave you a home was a
wonderful father spent time with you and
your brother and held your mother at
night and loved her truly
is he not still a great man yeah no he
is yeah I vote Yes yeah I agree I'll
vote yes for sure I agree and that's the
other thing like they'll they'll use
that in divorce court and say that's a
reason a guy shouldn't get his kids and
I'm just like what does it have to do
they do they'll say oh he cheated well
so yeah and he did yeah so you can't say
I cheat because I'm on the internet
saying it yeah like yo this one and
that's another thing it's been so
helpful to me you know you talk about
your first year online there's two
things that we should talk about number
one I have enough content out there that
once a girl even thinks she's interested
in me the first thing she does like a
girl will do is go watch everything I
ever said online so they already know
so you'd be sitting there and she's like
so
about this multiple girls thing what
about it
or what about it you like blondes
brunettes
I'm surprised how many girls turn by
real fast you've got the right man
sitting in front of them being a redhead
unless why are the redheads always
discriminated against yeah right that's
really so funny do you remember a
miracle online you're probably too young
no I don't know okay so basically
there's this thing called America Online
AOL when I was in like I don't know like
sixth grade but the first thing you do
it wasn't like normal social media it
was chat rooms right
so to ask you you know like what's your
you know what do you eyes color location
and when I would say redhead they'd be
like gotta go you know like if you were
to tell a girl with your girlfriends hey
I'm dating this redheaded guy you know
they'd be like the that's true yeah
that's true for sure only women are hot
redheads
yeah that's true you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah Ginger's a tough life
Kick a Ginger Day
I like being a ginger I do too yeah me
too I I like to joke and say I'm the
most handsome ginger man on the planet I
feel like we're mutations you know yeah
it's it's not the easiest thing would
you want to be kind of a hybrid Ginger
you know you don't want to be like the
see-through Ginger I am you you at least
tan I know I know I got some I don't
know I got something in me somewhere
where I can tan yeah but
yeah Ginger's tough but back to the
online thing
putting my content out there has been
very helpful because it's kind of like a
filter
you know and um
and then also I've learned that people
online are
like past the level that I could have
even imagined so like when you're
talking about how people come at you and
they attack you sometimes I'm reading
comments I'm like wow
that person
like not only said it but thinks it no
way
so it's really interesting
I don't see I don't think I deal with it
well to be honest you take it personal
yeah I do really I have a hard time with
it sometimes why I don't know
I wish I didn't but yeah I would say
like I don't want it to wail
what do you mean a whale fat chick oh
yeah I don't really wait a second are
you fat shaming yeah I do not I
know Big's beautiful right it's not um I
openly fat shame here I think yeah oh
good I think like we shouldn't be fat
and we should all be trying to get in
better shape oh good and I feel like
yeah so if it like um a big I believe
you said that I'm so disappointed look
at it I'm and then and then they'll come
at me they'll be like don't you know
that big is beautiful it's not it's not
beautiful it's not I don't know what
they're it's just like the fat chicks
are always so mad they're fat yeah those
are always a feminist yes and so if I
were president I would make Lane Bryant
shut down immediately like you want to
wear clothes then fit in them
[Laughter]
feminist comes for me I don't care it's
like whatever you're a fat feminist who
bothers you
I would just say it's been hard having
like friends like turn on me
where it's like you you kind of start at
a certain level with them and then you
get up to a certain level and it's like
they get
you know they make a hit piece or like
then they feel entitled oh friends from
the space
no not even the space like sometimes it
would just be people like I knew or
whatever back in the day yeah I had
relationships with those people now
such a conversation
um well I had one friend who she stopped
being friends with me we were friends
for 20 years and I I I made a comment
about the whales you know I do go in on
the way you know and okay I didn't do
that okay I didn't know she gained that
much weight you know yeah it's like
I'm not watching your Facebook
yeah yeah she lived far away so I hadn't
seen her in a minute right so she
freaking like said she didn't want to be
my friend anymore so I just said okay
see you and then it's like then she
would get madder and I'm like you said
you didn't want to like I'm not gonna
argue with you and then it was like out
of the blue a freaking year later she's
like making hit like videos about me and
like like she would do this like passive
aggressive thing where she's like trying
to say something without say I don't
know right you know and it's just like
plenty of it and it's just like it
always comes back from your hometown
yeah mostly yeah no it does and it's
just like and and then it's like they
run a narrative that's it's not true
like she was saying oh she doesn't
really believe any of this and I'm like
you were a feminist I didn't want
to tell you because you were crazy
like why would I go out of my way to
tell you my opinions on society when
you're you're you know it's just like
yeah all complete no I'm completely with
you I've dealt with quite a bit of it
myself yeah and you know what uh you
know what though it's been one of the
most freeing things of my life
because one of the biggest reasons
outside of making sure that I had
already gotten to a place where I
deserved to speak about it
was
not wanting people to dislike me because
of it or worried about what they thought
and what I really came to realize for
myself is that all of the people that
did dislike me doing YouTube
secretly dislike me anyway
really and all the people that actually
you know like let's say with me
all they did was congratulate me and
it's been that way and I found that the
love 100x is more than the hate and most
of the hate that I actually get in any
kind of comments or anything comes from
an avatar and any it's true for me and
any hate that I get
outside of that is mostly Bahama back
and not even online I hear about it
Through the Grapevine and it's not even
really hate it's more like just people
put my name in their mouth you know
which I quite enjoy I love living in
their head which was is something very
new to me I never liked it before I
never thought I would like it I need to
have more of that mentality it's like
hard for me bro honest you're being a
be a bad
I don't know yeah but you know what I
appreciate that yeah because a lot of
people like living the show act like
they're tough things like that and just
tell the truth I am to the whales I am I
am worried about what the whales think
yeah and sometimes it's that way like
sometimes like I think it's very human
to have certain groups of people that
you want to like you I think that's
completely okay
disingenuousness is I think what makes
most people upset in the end you know
it's like acting one way but being
another or whatever you know if you
don't like the wells them I don't
like them either thank you yeah I don't
like them either it's just like I don't
even mind happy I don't mind whales that
are happy and they know it and and they
don't even have to make fun of
themselves or anything like that it's
like the ones that either are trying to
make a change and maybe they've been
unsuccessful you know that happens right
but they don't live in the delusion of
saying everyone has to think they're hot
right I got no beef with those whales
right in fact I respect those girls I
won't even yeah I was like I might stop
calling them whales I wouldn't call them
well at all I'd be very dude yeah
because I wouldn't want to hurt their
feelings because it's about being a good
human at that point it's the
well do you know how this started this
way up my whale Moby Dick no no I'm
gonna tell you that it's a whale Quest
oh please dude so I was I was doing the
greatest catch I was doing I was doing
Street interviews okay and I was
interviewing this now I'm not gonna say
it but if I had to say whale now now
yeah and we were talking about going
home at night like safety and I was just
telling her like she was saying oh I
can't walk home alone at night and I'm
like well we're walking now like I don't
you know and then she and then I was
like why don't you just not live in a
major city
you know and live somewhere safe there
you go you know and then this or not
walk at night and she just got so mad
that she not knocks the mic out of my
hand and she's trying to attack like
she's trying to attack me I had a friend
with me at the time he pulled her back
right and she's literally trying to
attack me and he's pulling her I'll have
you you slack and I didn't know what
slag meant so I knew I was being
insulted though yeah and so then I was
just like well you're a whale anyway
that's how it started because I was well
attacked you got whale attacked I got
whale I mean she didn't hit me I mean
she did knock the mic out but she didn't
you know that's how it happens man
sometimes you just get whale attacked
and then you hate him forever well some
people hate dogs
yeah they always say who hurt you that
whale
I'm glad you said that that's one thing
that gets used against men quite a bit
is guilt
um
who hurt you a real man would do this
you're ugly anyways yeah well man that's
the thing you say to a woman but like
those things where you're trying to call
a man out on his masculinity by not
doing what you want him to do
I've seen women try that it's a very low
level tactic men fall for it hard you
know
so not to get off the whale subject
no we should move on I've given I've
given them enough you don't want to make
t-shirts
well we were kind of we wanted to we
actually I had a whole merch no I swear
I had a whole merch line ready to go and
it had the types of whales on it and it
was like beluga whale and it like had
literal whales and then in the middle it
had an entitled whale and then it had a
whale with a wig on it but we were
afraid we'd lose the channel so we're
like bro and you can get canceled around
hurting feelings now yeah
that's crazy so we had to we had to stop
the whale merch but I really I'm still
sad to this day I did like you hear that
it's like the hurt in my blood
you can't oh you can't do that it'll
Rumble maybe but I feel like you could
do on Rumble that'll get you
canceled on YouTube at some point
possibly
we'll see it's a crazy world I mean they
canceled Andrew and he didn't even have
a YouTube account right you really had
to take confidential yeah Oh I thought
he didn't have one
I think he had two channels actually his
Clips were just oh okay I didn't realize
that I think he did the emergency
meeting on one channel then you had to
take confidential oh okay so that's
basically how it broke out are you gonna
move to rumble
I don't promote it as much so we'll see
we'll see what happens I I heard that
the CEO is really cool though we'll see
we'll see I I put all my videos on there
I just don't promote it are you
promoting it
are you gonna do it
maybe
um I've spoken I've gone back and forth
with them a bit so maybe
um I just don't I don't know yet
it's kind of tough because they just
don't pay that well and at the end of
the day like it is a business so it's
like
you know until they figure something out
with that right it's tough but I really
do like the platform and I do really
believe in freedom of speech and I think
it's a shame like the direction that
YouTube's going in so I do know that it
is a possibility that this could all go
you know yeah it's scary it's scary to
know that somebody can just hit a button
you know and then that's your livelihood
too you know because a lot of people
will be on the internet for like 10 20
years building this whole platform and
it's like with one button the powers
that be can just take it all away yeah
it's a great it's a crazy situation and
again I think it you know 100 200 years
from now they're gonna look back and be
like that was nuts they wasn't
arguing about whether the but
clearly she was fat why are we not
trying to figure out why we're flying
through space on a rock why did
nobody want to help Elon a little more
you know
so which is a crazy thought right we're
sitting here talking about this you're
arguing with some fat on the
street
I would truly like to know where's the
other Earth at you know what I'm saying
like if you want to like put into
perspective right you know like what if
the sun goes out next week what if it's
like okay I'm done fizzle out like you
don't like we don't know these things
right it's crazy you know
you're you're squaring up with a
bluegill well in London
so
I think she's more like a killer whale
oh was she killer whale nice y'all
should stay in touch
I'm good I'm good on her and then I got
privacy complainted too I gotta
obviously complain yeah yeah she
wouldn't get out of my shot like she
kept getting in the camera and then she
privacy complainted my video
interesting yeah anyways
um sorry I just sometimes I have to let
out my anger about the whales do it do
it it's it's out I'm good I'm good I'm
good but thank you so much for coming
it's fun um tell the people where they
can find you yeah so you can go on
YouTube Jay Waller on Instagram for now
it's Justin Wynn Waller that's
j-u-s-t-i-n-win
w i n Waller wall
w-a-l-l-e-r-7 on Instagram
thank you so much for coming and thank
you for being one of the first people
that collaborate I always really
appreciate the first people that
collaborated with me because
life was rough back then it was tough to
get anyone to come so I'll find talent
for a living so I knew I knew what I was
doing
um thank you guys for watching the
stream um make sure you like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time
foreign
[Music]